more than maybe any other League of
Legends player enric a expec a say
Daniel Martinez is a man of two legacies
one is his history as a player one of
the game's most renowned from the
earliest days of organized competitive
play he is one incredible victories and
won fans with his playful attitude the
other is the organization he built its
rise from challenger to incredible
competitive heights and then its
disappearance in 2017 it's really been a
crazy story of what used to or what
could have been a very successful
organization with one firmly cemented
and the other now in question the story
of a mid laner who captured the
imagination and excitement of a young
eSports audience is more relevant than
ever thank you hi god make a hit taking
events because their words I have lead
these so many times
this is expec a story born in Spain on
April 24th 1992 expec 8 would rise to
prominence during league of legends
early days while the game was officially
released in 2009 it was in July 2010
that season 1 began a ranked matchmaking
hue that included draft it was where
many early pros including expect a about
their start pekae became known as a top
laner on ladder and would find his way
onto osk gaming that lineup did well
enough to be picked up by my revenge but
two months later in March 2011 the squad
was acquired by fnatic two months later
the team competed at the European
qualifier for the first ever League of
Legends World Championship scraping by
as Europe's third seed the main
tournament saw three teams from Europe
and North America and a single team from
both Singapore and Thailand faced off
but a travel issue caused expect a to be
late to the tournament and the team had
to
we will fail her as a substitute pecky
did rejoin the team after the first day
and while they had a rough start to the
tournament fnatic made it out of their
group and marched their way through the
bracket and that is AGG fnatic leads to
over CLG needing one here at Dreamhack
I'm happy
XP games making the difference there now
odds that the Nexus will it be an EU
winner's bracket final looks like it
will automatically win this series 2 to
0 will reach the winner's bracket final
against against all authority Oh going
to win the season 1 changes if they can
hold on this mixes will go down
congratulate the climatic women the
season 1 the accepted meta of the game
was still changing and the tournament
itself held at Dreamhack summer 2011 in
Jean shopping Sweden was dark and loud
but regardless of how you view it in the
greater structure of the modern LCS
system it was a big deal back then the
game had world champions and Pekka was
one of them now I would like to thanks
my mom because I'm pretty sure she's
watching me right now and it's all a
fancy fnatic played in a number of
tournaments during the latter part of
2011 including a dominant undefeated
first place run at IEM new york which
saw expec a moved to the mid lane as the
meta began to set fnatic there you'll
have a 2-0 victory to win Intel Extreme
Masters New York the beginning of 2012
was a relatively quiet period for
competitive league of legends in the
West but fnatic were one of two Western
teams to travel to Seoul to compete in
the Champions the field was
predominantly Korean and left out of the
World Championship it was an opportunity
to test themselves against the region
though they made it out of the group
stage fnatic would fall to eventual
third place finishers team Opie and the
orders Oh dominating every single game
fanatic giving them more of a run for
their money than anyone else but in the
end go down Opie claims the last spot in
the semi-finals
despite that expect a was already in the
conversation as one of the best mid
laners in the world and he would soon
have a chance to prove it in June 2012
fnatic removed shushei and MELAS on left
due to school so the team had it so as
and fail ox in their places
despite the moves the team did not place
high enough to make it to the season 2
world championship but the August 2012
announcement of a new format for
competitive league of legends would soon
change the history of the game forever
season 3 plans have been released from
riot going to be really exciting for the
NA nd you seen they're actually going to
have two matches every week the league
would hold qualifiers to admit the
initial teams and fnatic got to work
playing in a number of unrelated
tournaments in the interim it was during
this time that expec a most famous
moment took place in the group stage at
IEM katowice fnatic found itself
opposite SK gaming and expec a facedown
fellow Spanish mid laner Carlos Ocelot
Rodriguez fnatic vs. SK gaming goes back
many many years are you aware of that
storied rival yeah but were even Helio
players who have been
for like two years later I see each
other and already saw is on a story
after defending their Nexus in appeared
that sk-gaming
would march toward fanatics base and
finished the job that they're super
minions had started
that is until pekae provided us with one
of the most memorable wall moments of
all time
the expected you can see is covered in
that is definitely uphold the Nexus he's
trying to do it but be more in the face
yeah that starts trying to defend him in
the face he's trying to take the next
[Applause]
speckies rival and fellow countryman
didn't hold back his emotions in the
postgame interview I don't know I'm
really really destroy but expec a was
gracious in victory yeah the way you
played today are definitely a lot of
team in a warm
the inaugural EU LCS season began in
February and fnatic made their mark on
the league's first split with a twenty
two and six first place finish enroute
to a Grand Finals win against gambit
game the grand final winners will be
fanatic take it down kami kami three two
two what a fantastic
expec a was also leaving his own mark
his personable attitude and tendency to
joke around made him a celebrity in a
league that was just starting to choose
its own heroes welcome to the blog he
tells the story of last night well last
night we don't like last night pretty
much we wanted to get drunk and I just
got one beer in four hours that was not
that was not the plan at all heck a
continued his strong play into the
summer split as the team took second
overall and then again in twenty
playoffs they're gonna be going to Los
Angeles as the number one seed the
spring split champions and the summer
split champions fnatic the reigning
champions of Europe qualifying for
world's 2013 with a dominant 7 1 group
stage performance that saw them lose
only to team Vulcan fnatic burst through
the bracket defeating Enys cloud9 to 2y
but it is going to be another triple for
becca hiccups a Quadra they're gonna
give it to him yes they are
it is Peck a dominating 1107 fnatic are
gonna go through to the semi-finals
taken down the North American champions
cloud nine of the six Western teams at
the tournament they were the only one to
make top four with 80 carry Martin
reckless Larsson finally of age to play
in the EU LCS expectations for the team
were higher than ever in 2014 he moved
to the starting roster in November and
the team then took a second place finish
at IEM cologne fnatic did meet
expectations in spring as I finished
second in the regular season enroute to
yet another u LCS title qualifying for
all-star Paris as a result pekae again
found himself at an international
tournament against a hot new mid laner
as KT telecom t1
thinker it will be Cassidy fake to fake
a playmaker we've all seen the video
we've all seen what he has well to the
party he's in trouble man do comes in
bow not able to get away and that's a
double for SK Telecom
faker would get the upper hand and
fnatic went one in three in groups
meaning they had to face SKT in the
semi-finals they lost that series too
but the crowd in Paris nonetheless
chanted for them as they left the stage
and the tournament
[Applause]
their support
[Applause]
while summer 2014 got off to a rough
start the team rallied in the latter
weeks took second and Ward into the
playoff finals against Alliance their
second place finish was good enough to
send pecky to Worlds for the third time
but the task ahead of them was daunting
as they shared a group with Korean first
seed samsung blue Chinese third seed oh
my god and any third seed lmq do you
kind of have a now-or-never feeling
approach to this determinant yes but but
you always had that feeling and every
since even after season 1 I had this
feeling already that this now or never
if we don't win this season I don't know
what's next I have the same season too I
had the same season 3 and I have the
exact same feeling right now that
because you don't know what's coming
next
it's always really scary if it felt like
the chance at a second worlds victory
for a Western team with slowly slipping
away this tournament confirmed it and
there are so many individual mistakes
from fnatic here though expect a had
plenty of highly pleased in the group
stage realizer
it's all about finding fights a spark
going down what is he gonna be enough
Starling is gonna be
to finish Alfea the fanatics to and for
record was not enough to get them out of
groups the only Western teams to make it
out were cloud nine and TSM and neither
fought their way into the top for the
off season brought big change for Peck a
as both he and cyanide left fanatic but
while the jungler was retiring Peck a
had other plans
his second legacy would begin in 2015 my
name is Enrique my nickname is ex Becca
I prefer team Orion as a mid laner expec
a created eSports organization origin
and assembled a roster of promising
talent with the goal of fighting through
challenger to qualify for the LCS I
think I have been three or four years
saying fnatic pretty much and I hone
saying I play for Orion if feels it was
really weird
feels like I'm not even playing the same
game like expect a top laner so as was a
veteran of the early competitive scene
and had played with pekae on fnatic it
was a good opportunity to pull myself
again
amazing the team's jungler had just come
off a stint with North America's Team
solomid even if they would be passed at
prime they would be still be better than
than 75% of tests in the ACS mithy the
team support was previously a member of
lemon dogs and ninjas and pyjamas he had
been banned since June for toxicity but
with his band now served origin offer
him a chance at redemption I felt that
the best way for me to start from
scratch with a team with respected
players and show that I am like anyone
can change and I'm different the team
sought out meals who would later change
his handle to Sven
as the team's ad carry I even asked
reckless I remember as I asked him we
tell you what you think would be the
best and he told me if you go with this
guy Niels I'm pretty sure you guys were
qualified and of course [ __ ] would hold
down the mid lane getting to LCS is the
number one priority and for me it's
actually the only priority but whether
or not Pekka was thinking about it
Origen was building height
and qualified for the Challenger series
with ease once there they put up a nine
one record
losing only a single game before rolling
over reason gaming and copenhagen wolves
academy enroute to the EU LCS summer
welcome to the LCS because you've just
donate to this series you take in the
first place in the spring split of the
challenger series congratulations and if
there was any question about expec agent
in you'd popularity as one of europe's
legendary mid laners that was settled
when he appeared on the analysis desk
for the EU LCS spring finals in spain
while the hype was building for origins
debut and pekka's return it still wasn't
clear how they would stack up against
the competition are you guys is there
anyone you're specifically looking out
for that you haven't played before that
you have played before um for me I'm
mostly looking for fnatic with the with
wreckless coming back to the team I
think it's a really great addition to
for them to play against someone that
you played with because it feels so
different when you play with people and
then you play against them you see stuff
that they do that you didn't realize or
that they didn't do so is is good to get
a different point of view when you play
against all teammates with this team
legit or were they simply a mix of
veteran experience and upcoming skill
trouncing challenger as fnatic put up an
undefeated 18 and our season Origen
proved that they too were one of
Europe's powerhouses and now deals is it
oh they just want to go for it he's got
a ton coming in from so ass they won't
even need a right
as the rest of the team is there 1 2 & 3
they peel the bark off the tree and they
can take dragon for free original I'm
looking for another team finest Brady
has managed to throw it away origins but
a long-range asset hunter secures
another kill for Niels and soaz is
teleported in he's with the equalised
the town he's got himself a double kill
he's burning them down as Niels gets a
double of his own in the playoffs they
reached the final original fnatic will
be picking up game 1 in this
best-of-five live from stockholm sweden
reckless is luke pick is gonna start
charging the piercing arrow he's gonna
snipe reckless but not enough to kill
former teammates chasing them down
penetrate reckless is on and fnatic lose
4 for the first time in 3 12 weeks 6
patches
- frenetic run stock and its origin
they hinted fnatic their first loss of
the season but Origen couldn't close out
the series Falling in the fifth and
final game
you gotta game for both kill of the
fight so has survives but it does not
matter fnatic are cheering upon origins
base there's 40 seconds on the timer
fnatic in Game five of the summer split
going to the neck but origin could still
make it to Worlds all they had to do was
win the Europe regional finals after a
close series against Roccat Origen flew
away unicorns of love to earn their spot
the second-best team in Europe
Origen pushing fnatic all the way
getting pushed by rocket obliterates
unicorns of love booked their tickets to
Paris Origen had made it to Worlds but
it was clear that even as Europe's third
seed the rest of the tournament field
wasn't expecting much from expect I
don't think we have to prove anything
because the fans were counting us out
already
Origen were the underdogs in a group
with LGD gaming team solomid and kt
rolster not a single player from origins
roster had been highlighted in riot
games pre-tournament list of the world's
top 20 players the rest of their group
had six even expect him self came under
fire from observers when expect is the
worst mid laner in their group some
people even say in the whole world
tournament
but if expec aid was the weakest mid
laner at Worlds
he didn't play like it takes a lot of
damage to us right to get to the
backline he did get hit by emo play
expect his ok big ego
and if some analysts were expecting
origin to roll over and die they were
disappointed against LGD origin
displayed classic expec a and so as
sharp slowly but surely get enough
damage that he has to GT
and team solomid underestimated them at
their peril sister it's an origin the
trend continues these guys are looking
great and they're gonna take down team
solomid even so could the team defeat
Korean powerhouse kt rolster they answer
that question with a statement
an undefeated week one against some of
the tournament's best teams and on
European soil no less Origen had already
shown that their veterans were more than
capable of keeping up with the greatest
in the world
I never thought we would be able to
compete at walls and if we actually got
to qualify the wars I never thought will
be a contender there week two wasn't
quite as successful as I dropped games
against Katie and LGD therefore and to
record was good enough to enter the
bracket as the group's second seed
facing flash wolves in the best-of-five
quarterfinals flash Wells our origin
I've got with the flash goes giving it
to the flash wolves what followed was
classic x-pac a classic Origen played
just what do you think they're going for
a dragon they go for your base
[Applause]
without even getting to kill origin drop
the Nexus in game one origin went up two
games in their series against flash
wolves their opponents from Taiwan
struck back
but origin secured their spot in
Brussels in-game origin moved on to the
semi-finals where expect his path to the
finals was blocked by a familiar foe SK
Telecom t1 epic is aluminum battle or in
colonies also given a toy toys and a
dodo a dado cotton Isaiah 1000 well
origin lost Game one it seemed like they
could contest the series but after a
game 2 loss game 3 went out with a
whimper
there's no stopping him now it's time
for SKT to make it to the finals
undefeated
no one would have expected Origen to
even make it this far but the loss still
stung and the European crowd made sure
that their appreciation was heard one
split an unlikely roster and a trip from
challenger and their gaming house and
Spain's Canary Islands to world semies
2015 had been a good year for expeced
who had balanced his role as the team's
mid laner against his duties as owner
but in 2016
even after his own strong performance at
Worlds he decided it was time to start
stepping back the team announced a six
player roster that included mid laner
power of evil intending to split time
between him and Pekka but in reality
pekae had already moved away from the
game in a big way playing only three
games in the team's 11 and 7 2016 spring
split I still wanna play I hope I can do
it
sooner than later to be honest the team
again made it to the playoff finals the
pekka's old rival Ocelot had been busy
assembling a roster for his own
organization g2 eSports and Origen would
again have to settle for second we lost
against g2 3-1 but really felt really
really subtle going play one game on a
loose Origen did not improve in the
summer both meals and mithy went to his
old rivals team g2 eSports an Origin
signed veteran Greek ad carry forgiven
and Dutch support hybrid to replace the
team struggled early and forgiving left
the team after three weeks citing
problems with motivation Pekka chose not
to replace forgiving
and instead played ad carry himself and
almost a year removed from a top four
finish at Worlds origin posted a 12 and
24 record and had to play the promotion
tournament to retain their spot in the
EU LCS Origen stayed alive just barely
and it is all Nexus origin welcome back
to the LCS that is a massive sigh of
relief for pekae and the Archon
organization heading into season 7 the
team's roster was completely rebuilt
with only pekae remaining in the lineup
as a substitute
they added satorious wisdom Mahan tabs
and Hiva
but pekae washed as his dream and the
organization he had built slowly slipped
back toward the possibility of
relegation pecky again inserted himself
into the starting lineup this time
playing support as the team released
Hiva specky he is an incredible player
and he has a long and storied history
and now he's playing his third role on
the LCS stage it wasn't enough with a 0
and 13 regular season record the team
fell to the promotion tournament where
they didn't win a single game and were
relegated expec his legacy as a player
and personality is firmly cemented the
backdoor play he popularized will likely
bear his name forever in League of
Legends and his infectious personality
and flashy style have made him a fan
favorite but his organization's legacy
is in jeopardy in summer 2017 the team
tried unsuccessfully to climb out of
challenger but then basically dropped
off the map then in 2018 the
organization announced funding from
soccer star álvaro Arbeloa they signed a
number of veteran pros to compete in the
you Masters Tournament top their group
and took the event but can origin who
captured the imaginations of so many EU
LCS fans rise again it's a question
unanswered for the moment still when the
chips are down and he's got that
signature grin on his face it's hard to
bet against its back thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button